This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars and I'm in the studio with Christopher Johnson. Hey, Christopher. Hey, Roman. So I want you to do something for me, okay? And I'm coming in kind of hot, all right? Okay. Okay. So I want you to picture in your head an image of Jesus Christ, okay? Specifically, the Jesus that you saw in your imagination when you were growing up. that you saw in your imagination when you were growing up? Um, okay. When I was growing up, okay. Um, this does feel like a trap.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯，现在和克里斯托弗·约翰逊在录音室里。嘿，克里斯托弗。嘿，罗曼。我想让你帮我做件事，好吗？我这可是开门见山了，行吗？行。好的。我想让你在脑海中想象一下耶稣基督的形象，好吗？具体来说，就是你成长过程中在想象中看到的那个耶稣。你在成长过程中在想象中看到的那个？嗯，好吧。我成长过程中，好吧。嗯，这感觉像个陷阱。
But I will play along. So mostly I'm picturing a kind of, you know, flowy brown hair, you know, a peaceful face, lean, bearded, white with blue eyes. I recognize what territory we're getting into here with blue eyes. Okay, good. You know, but like a nice surfer, like a mild, peaceful, nice surfer.
但我会配合你的。我脑海中浮现的主要是那种，你知道，飘逸的棕色头发，你知道，一张平静的脸，清瘦，留着胡须，白人，蓝眼睛。我意识到我们正在进入什么领域了，蓝眼睛。好吧，很好。你知道，就像一个不错的冲浪者，那种温和、平静、友好的冲浪者。
Yeah, same. Listen, this is not a trap, man. And the way that you described him, that's exactly how I grew up thinking about Jesus too. And a lot of our listeners may have also grown up seeing this same mental image of Jesus. And so what I'm here to tell you today is that that mental image that's in so many of our heads,
是的，我也是。听着，这可不是陷阱，伙计。你描述他的方式，和我成长过程中对耶稣的印象一模一样。我们很多听众可能也是从小就带着这个同样的耶稣心理形象长大的。所以我今天想告诉你的是，我们许多人脑海中那个心理形象，
that idea of what Jesus looks like, it actually comes in large part from one single painting that was made in 1940 in Chicago. It was called The Head of Christ. And it's the single most popular, most ubiquitous image of Jesus in the world. Wow, okay. So here, let me show it to you. Yep, that's the dude.
那个关于耶稣长相的观念，其实很大程度上源于1940年在芝加哥创作的一幅画。它叫《基督头像》。它是世界上最受欢迎、最无处不在的耶稣形象。哇，好吧。来，我给你看看。没错，就是这个家伙。
He's kind of three quarters of a profile, blue eyes, white, thin, lean, trim beard. He's got this sort of soft glow around him as he looks softly into the distance. But yeah, that's the Jesus. That's the guy, right? And this Head of Christ painting is, by some accounts, the single best knownknown piece of American
他大约是四分之三侧面，蓝眼睛，白人，清瘦，留着整齐的胡须。当他柔和地望向远方时，周围有一种柔和的光晕。但没错，这就是那个耶稣。就是这个人，对吧？而这幅《基督头像》画作，据某些说法，是整个20世纪最著名的美国艺术作品。
artwork of the whole 20th century. It's been reproduced a billion times and spread all over the planet. And it has shaped so many of the popular depictions of Jesus that we know. And just up front here, like, we don't know much about what Jesus actually looked like, right? We don't, and the Bible doesn't tell us a whole lot. But that fact hasn't stopped anybody. Artists have been creating images of Jesus for many, many centuries all over the world.
它被复制了十亿次，传遍了全球。它塑造了我们所知的许多关于耶稣的流行描绘。首先要说明的是，我们并不太清楚耶稣到底长什么样，对吧？我们确实不知道，圣经也没有告诉我们太多。但这个事实并没有阻止任何人。几个世纪以来，世界各地的艺术家一直在创作耶稣的形象。
Yeah, so, so Joy and I went and saw the blast supper in Milan, like in person last year. And I didn't really think about it much at the time, but I just kind of pulled it up as we were talking to see how different it was from this head of Christ image that you just showed me. And it's really different. So that there's lots of different images of Jesus out there and some of them are very famous, like The Last Supper.
是的，所以，去年我和乔伊亲自去米兰看了《最后的晚餐》。当时我没怎么想，但刚才我们谈话时我把它调出来看了看，想看看它和我刚才给你看的这幅《基督头像》有多大区别。确实非常不同。所以，外面有很多不同的耶稣形象，其中一些非常出名，比如《最后的晚餐》。
And so how did this one painting, Head of Christ, come to dominate all of our images of Jesus in our heads? Okay, so that story starts with a Chicago artist named Warner Salmon. Back in the 1920s, Salmon was a commercial illustrator who did ads for pianos and toothbrushes and trucks and suits and stuff like that. He was also a Christian and he volunteered to be the art director for this new magazine for young people that his church had just started. And in early 1924, he was on deadline to draw something for the cover art.
那么，这幅《基督头像》是如何主宰我们脑海中所有耶稣形象的呢？好吧，这个故事始于一位名叫华纳·萨尔曼的芝加哥艺术家。回到20世纪20年代，萨尔曼是一位商业插画家，为钢琴、牙刷、卡车、西装之类的东西做广告。他也是一名基督徒，并自愿担任他教会刚创办的一本青少年杂志的艺术总监。1924年初，他正赶着为封面画画。
And is he trying to draw Jesus, like put Jesus on the issue of this magazine? Kind of like Oprah's on every cover of Oprah magazine? Or what? I mean, you know, he's the art director for this kids Christian magazine. I guess he could make whatever he wanted. But then, Salman suddenly got artist block. Is there such a thing as artist block?
他是想画耶稣，把耶稣放在这本杂志的封面上吗？就像奥普拉出现在每一期《奥普拉杂志》封面上那样？还是怎么回事？我是说，你知道，他是这本儿童基督教杂志的艺术总监。我想他可以画任何他想画的东西。但后来，萨尔曼突然遇到了创作瓶颈。真的有创作瓶颈这种东西吗？
He said he had been working on it for a while, and nothing worked out. He was unsatisfied with everything he tried. This is Jack Lundbaum. He's Warner Solomon's biographer, and the two were good friends. And, yeah, it came close to the deadline. He went to sleep, and during the night,
他说他已经为此工作了一段时间，但什么都不行。他对尝试的一切都不满意。这是杰克·伦德鲍姆。他是华纳·萨尔曼的传记作者，两人是好朋友。而且，是的，快到截止日期了。他去睡觉了，在夜里，
he had a dream or a vision in which he saw this picture in his mind's eye. So he got out of bed and he penciled out kind of a first draft and the next day he turned that into a larger charcoal sketch. Okay so what did this charcoal drawing look like? So this was a very simple black charcoal sketch of Jesus's head. This is still 15 years before Solomon would make his world famous Head of Christ painting. And this drawing is much more basic than that. But the template is definitely there
他做了一个梦或是一个幻象，在脑海中看到了这幅画。于是他起床用铅笔画出了草稿，第二天把它变成了一幅更大的木炭素描。好吧，那这幅木炭画长什么样？这是一幅非常简单的耶稣头像黑色木炭素描。这还是在萨尔曼创作那幅举世闻名的《基督头像》画作的15年前。这幅画比那幅要基础得多。但模板确实在那里，
and you can see the similarities. It's Jesus's head with long wavy hair, the trim beard and those soft, peaceful eyes gazing off into the distance. And in his biography or in the story of his life, is there ever an explanation as to why he drew Jesus this way? Why did the drawing come out like this?
你可以看到相似之处。那是耶稣的头，留着长长的波浪发，整齐的胡须，还有那双柔和、平静、望向远方的眼睛。在他的传记或他的人生故事里，有没有解释他为什么这样画耶稣？为什么这幅画会画成这样？
Well, there are a few answers. One answer, of course, is that this is the image that he saw in his vision. Sure. But there are a couple of other reasons too. People had depicted Jesus for a long time before Warner Solomon sat down. And Solomon admitted he'd seen some of those
嗯，有几个答案。当然，一个答案是这就是他在幻象中看到的形象。当然。但还有其他几个原因。在华纳·萨尔曼动笔之前，人们已经描绘耶稣很长时间了。萨尔曼承认他看过其中一些，
and he got inspiration from those. But probably the biggest thing that inspired Solomon was that in the mid-1920s, around the time that he made this drawing, there was this growing general concern that American Christian men were getting soft. Part of that anxiety was stoked by changes in work. People were becoming more sedentary, there were more office jobs, and folks were worried that men were getting more sluggish
并从中获得了灵感。但可能最激励萨尔曼的是，在20世纪20年代中期，也就是他创作这幅画的时候，人们普遍担心美国基督徒男性正在变得软弱。这种焦虑部分是由工作变化引起的。人们变得越来越久坐，办公室工作多了，人们担心男性变得越来越懒散，
and putting on weight. This was especially problematic for Christians, who felt that a man of God was supposed to be exemplary and disciplined and strong, not some schlubby pencil pusher. On top of that, white Protestants like Salman were really freaked out about cities. Oh, there was a real concern that city life zapped, zapped moral goodness and energy. This is David Morgan. He's an art historian who teaches religious studies at Duke. And he's written a lot about Salman's artwork. Salman was very much a part of this discourse about the, particularly the effect on men,
并且体重增加。这对基督徒来说尤其成问题，他们认为上帝的子民应该是模范、自律和强壮的，而不是什么邋遢的文职人员。最重要的是，像萨尔曼这样的白人新教徒对城市感到非常恐惧。哦，人们确实担心城市生活会消耗道德善良和活力。这是大卫·摩根。他是一位在杜克大学教授宗教研究的艺术史学家。他写了很多关于萨尔曼艺术作品的文章。萨尔曼非常关注这种论述，特别是对男性的影响，
that they lost their masculinity, they became effeminate, they became preoccupied with the pleasures of a city life that would distract from moral mission and fail to recognize what was supposed to make them different from the world. And so one reaction to this was this movement that was called muscular Christianity. The movement started in England and was picked up by Protestants in the US, who felt that they had to redefine what it meant to be a real Christian man. And so people like Salman, who were connected to that movement, that they had to redefine what it meant to be a real Christian man. And so people like Salman, who were connected to that movement, felt one of the best ways
他们失去了男子气概，变得女性化，沉迷于城市生活的享乐，从而偏离了道德使命，无法认识到是什么让他们与众不同。因此，对此的一种反应就是被称为“肌肉基督教”的运动。这场运动始于英国，并被美国的基督徒所采纳，他们觉得必须重新定义什么是真正的基督徒男性。所以像萨尔曼这样与该运动有关的人，觉得最好的方式之一
to inspire men, and especially young men and boys, to be more fit and strong and manly and courageous was to give them images of Jesus Christ that had those same qualities. There's this strong desire for a new image of Jesus. This is Edward Bloom. He's a historian who co-authored the book The Color of Christ, The Son of God, and The Saga of Race in America. There's a desire for a Jesus who would represent manliness and masculinity in a time when white men often feel like they're kind of losing their masculine identity.
就是激励男性，尤其是年轻男性和男孩，变得更健康、强壮、有男子气概和勇敢，给他们提供具有这些品质的耶稣基督形象。人们强烈渴望一个新的耶稣形象。这是爱德华·布鲁姆。他是一位历史学家，与人合著了《基督的肤色：上帝之子与美国的种族传奇》一书。人们渴望一个能代表男子气概的耶稣，尤其是在白人男性觉得正在失去男性身份的时代。
And so the 1924 drawing that Warner-Solman made for the Kids Magazine, that was his attempt at this. Yeah, yeah. But here's the thing. What's up? This image, it's not what I would, masculine is not the first word that would come to me. You know what I'm saying?
所以华纳·萨尔曼为儿童杂志创作的1924年画作，就是他对此的尝试。是的，是的。但问题是。怎么了？这个形象，不是我会用的词，男子气概不是我脑海中浮现的第一个词。你知道我的意思吗？
This is not stereotypically, this is a person who has a very, very gentle face. I mean, maybe the action of this moment is masculine, but this image doesn't scream that without that context. Hey, listen, I agree, but masculine was exactly what Warner Solomon was going for here. When Solomon produced his image, he was interviewed and he made this point that my image of Jesus, that drawing, represents a manly, in his phrase, a manly image of Christ that our young people need. And so how was this prototype, you know, head of Christ image received?
这不是刻板印象中的那种，这是一个面容非常、非常温柔的人。我是说，也许这一刻的动作是阳刚的，但没有那个背景，这个形象并不能体现这一点。嘿，听着，我同意，但“阳刚”正是华纳·萨尔曼所追求的。当萨尔曼创作他的形象时，他接受了采访，并指出我的耶稣形象，那幅画，代表了一种阳刚的，用他的话说是，我们年轻人需要的基督的阳刚形象。那么这个原型，你知道，这个《基督头像》形象是如何被接受的呢？
Well, Salmon's church members liked it a lot, but the image mostly just circulated inside that small, tight-knit religious community. Keep in mind, this is only in the Midwest. This is Solomon's friend and biographer, Jack Lombard, again. Really, his exposure was largely in covenant churches in the Chicago and Midwest. Very few people outside of the Midwest would have known the Solomon name or the picture. But this was all about to change, and what took this image to the next level was when
嗯，萨尔曼教会的成员非常喜欢它，但这个形象大多只是在那个小而紧密的宗教社区内流传。请记住，这只是在中西部。这是萨尔曼的朋友兼传记作者杰克·伦德鲍姆。实际上，他的曝光率主要是在芝加哥和中西部的盟约教会中。中西部以外很少有人知道萨尔曼这个名字或这幅画。但这即将改变，而将这个形象提升到新高度的是，
it went from a small black and white charcoal sketch to this full-size oil painting done in color. In the late 1930s, Salman met a couple of marketing reps who sold Christian goods. And one of them was this guy named Fred Bates. Fred Bates worked for a big company that was later named Warner Press. Warner Press made and sold all sorts of Christian-themed merch. You've seen this stuff, like thermometers, table sets, including plates and pans, lamps, pencils, mirrors, all with biblical mottos and scripture on them.
它从一幅小的黑白木炭素描变成了一幅全尺寸的彩色油画。20世纪30年代末，萨尔曼遇到了一对销售基督教商品的营销代表。其中一个是叫弗雷德·贝茨的人。弗雷德·贝茨为一家后来被称为华纳出版社的大公司工作。华纳出版社制作并销售各种基督教主题的商品。你见过这些东西，比如温度计、餐具套装，包括盘子和锅、灯、铅笔、镜子，上面都印有圣经格言和经文。
Warner Press started selling prints of Salman's simple black and white charcoal drawing. And then Fred Bates started whispering in Solomon's ear that they would love to see a version of this black and white drawing of Jesus done in color. Bates and his colleagues at Warner Press, they believe that a color version would have way more appeal to the masses. And why did Fred Bates think that a color version of Jesus would do so much better commercially than the black and white version they were already selling?
华纳出版社开始销售萨尔曼简单的黑白木炭画的印刷品。然后弗雷德·贝茨开始在萨尔曼耳边吹风，说他们很想看到这个黑白耶稣画的彩色版本。贝茨和他在华纳出版社的同事相信，彩色版本会对大众有更大的吸引力。为什么弗雷德·贝茨认为彩色版本的耶稣在商业上会比他们已经在销售的黑白版本好得多呢？
Because it would feel less like, you know, sketched art, which is kinda what the drawing really looked like, and more like a real portrait. The representatives of Warner Press said, you know, we think doing a color version of this would have added appeal and could be used in a variety of different ways. You could create little prayer cards. You could create color reproductions to frame and hang in the home. What they were talking about were commercial possibilities. Mostly, Salman just kind of ignored Bates's request. But then in 1940, Salman, on the low, actually did do a version that was a full-color oil painting. And he named that painting Head of Christ. Ah, so this is the painting that you showed me earlier.
因为这看起来不像，你知道，素描艺术，那确实是这幅画看起来的样子，而更像是一幅真正的肖像。华纳出版社的代表说，你知道，我们认为制作一个彩色版本会增加吸引力，并且可以以多种不同的方式使用。你可以制作小祈祷卡。你可以制作彩色复制品来装裱并挂在家里。他们谈论的是商业可能性。萨尔曼大多只是忽略了贝茨的要求。但后来在1940年，萨尔曼悄悄地做了一个全彩油画版本。他把那幅画命名为《基督头像》。啊，所以这就是你之前给我看的那幅画。
Jesus with three-quarters of a profile, gentle blue eyes, trim beard, white guy, that soft glow in the background looking off into the distance, all that. Exactly. And when Solomon first painted it, he just kind of hung it above the family piano and went on with his life. And then one night, Fred Bates stopped by Solomon's house and he saw the Head of Christ painting. And he was like, yes, this is it. He was totally enchanted.
四分之三侧面的耶稣，温柔的蓝眼睛，整齐的胡须，白人，背景中有那种柔和的光晕，望向远方，等等。没错。当萨尔曼第一次画它时，他只是把它挂在家庭钢琴上方，继续他的生活。然后有一天晚上，弗雷德·贝茨顺道拜访萨尔曼家，看到了《基督头像》这幅画。他当时就说，是的，就是这个。他完全被迷住了。
I mean, to him, this looked like the real guy. This is what he'd been asking for. And he loved this painting. And when Bates saw that, they said, you know, we think, you know, this sort of thing can sell. So they felt like we can take this from being a magazine illustration into a special object in domestic life. And I think their intuition was quite correct. So Warner Press did a print run of Head of Christ in various sizes, and they tested it,
我是说，对他来说，这看起来就像真人。这就是他一直要求的。他非常喜欢这幅画。当贝茨看到这一点时，他们说，你知道，我们认为，你知道，这种东西可以卖。所以他们觉得我们可以把它从杂志插图变成家庭生活中的特殊物品。我认为他们的直觉非常正确。所以华纳出版社印制了各种尺寸的《基督头像》，他们进行了测试，
and they tweaked the image. And then in early 1941, the first print run of 100,000 copies went out into the world. They were distributed through those Christian bookstores, through door-to-door salespeople, catalogs, and of course through churches. And that print run sold out, Roman, in two months. Jesus, well, that's a lot. By the end of the year, more than a million copies of the head of Christ image had been distributed.
并对图像进行了微调。然后在1941年初，第一批10万份印刷品推向了世界。它们通过那些基督教书店、上门推销员、目录，当然还有教会进行分发。罗曼，那批印刷品在两个月内就卖光了。天哪，那可真多。到年底，已经分发了超过一百万份《基督头像》图像。
And then over the next several years, four million more versions of the head of Christ image went out in all different sizes on all kinds of stuff like bookmarks, baptism announcements, obituaries, you name it. I mean, I can imagine it doing well. You know, it's a pretty painting of a man, you know? But surely this isn't the only contemporary color painting of Jesus that looks kind of realistic. Like, why was this one, why was Head of Christ in particular,
在接下来的几年里，又有四百万个版本的《基督头像》以各种尺寸出现在各种东西上，比如书签、洗礼公告、讣告，应有尽有。我是说，我可以想象它卖得很好。你知道，这是一幅漂亮的男人画，对吧？但肯定这不是唯一看起来有点写实的当代耶稣彩色画。那么，为什么这幅，为什么《基督头像》特别，
the one that was so wildly popular? Okay, so here's what art historian David Morgan says. He says that the difference was that this image, it looked like more than just a painting. It looked to a lot of people as if someone had taken a camera and snapped a real photo of a living Jesus Christ. When I was talking to people, and I would sometimes ask them, what is it you really like about this picture?
是那幅如此广受欢迎的画呢？好吧，艺术史学家大卫·摩根是这样说的。他说区别在于这幅画看起来不仅仅是一幅画。在许多人看来，就像有人拿着相机拍了一张活着的耶稣基督的真实照片。当我和人们交谈时，我有时会问他们，你真正喜欢这张照片的什么地方？
And some would say, well, because it's what Jesus really looked like. And some would say, frankly, it's a photograph of Jesus. I was struck by how they would regard authenticity in photographic terms. And so what David noticed was just how much this painting uses elements of what was then modern studio photography portraiture. This was super popular at the time that Salman made Head of Christ, especially for things like high school and college yearbook pictures. You would walk in, sit down, and there was a... There was a shtick, a visual shtick. This is how you pose.
有些人会说，嗯，因为这就是耶稣真实的样子。有些人会说，坦率地说，这是一张耶稣的照片。他们以摄影术语来看待真实性，这让我感到震惊。所以大卫注意到的是，这幅画在多大程度上使用了当时现代摄影肖像的元素。这在萨尔曼创作《基督头像》时非常流行，尤其是用于高中和大学毕业纪念册照片。你会走进去，坐下，然后有一个……有一个噱头，一个视觉噱头。这就是你摆姿势的方式。
This is what the photographer is looking for because that's how everybody thinks you need to be remembered. I mean, now that you've mentioned it, I totally didn't put it together, but it really does look like Jesus Christ's senior yearbook. Yes, exactly. And so like when you, you're right, when you look at the position of Christ's head, David says it has that three quarters pose. Typically looking away, looking off into the future, into the past, wherever, it gave you much of the face. And by the early 20th century, the three-quarter pose was considered the dignified look of eternity. This is how I will be remembered forever. And then there were the ways that Salman mimicked studio lighting to get that Sears portrait
这就是摄影师在寻找的东西，因为每个人都认为你需要这样被记住。我是说，既然你提到了，我完全没联想到一起，但它看起来确实像耶稣基督的高中毕业纪念册照片。是的，没错。所以当你，你是对的，当你看着基督头部的姿势时，大卫说它有那种四分之三的姿势。通常看向别处，看向未来，看向过去，无论哪里，它给了你大部分的面部。到20世纪初，四分之三姿势被认为是永恒的尊严外观。这就是我将被永远记住的方式。然后萨尔曼模仿摄影棚灯光来获得那种西尔斯肖像
studio gauziness that you see in Head of Christ. He uses yellows, whites, and tans to create the sense that Jesus is both emanating light and he's also lit up like he's in a studio. He decided, I think, creatively that this is how I'm going to show Jesus. This will give him a presence and a kind of relevance. And people said, this is what he really, one woman told me, this is what he really looked like. What she meant was it matched the image in her mind of what Jesus looked like. And when that happens, that clicks, that's why people form such a lively emotional connection to the picture. It's so remarkable that he's using a visual vernacular of this moment to create a portrait
摄影棚的朦胧感，你在《基督头像》中看到的。他使用黄色、白色和棕褐色来营造一种耶稣既散发着光芒，又像在摄影棚里一样被照亮的感觉。我想他在创作上决定，这就是我展示耶稣的方式。这会给他一种存在感和一种相关性。人们说，这就是他真实的样子，一位女士告诉我，这就是他真实的样子。她的意思是，这符合她脑海中耶稣长相的形象。当这种情况发生，产生共鸣时，这就是为什么人们会对这幅画形成如此生动的情感联系。他使用这一时刻的视觉白话来创作一幅
of Jesus that looks like a photograph, and then it matched the image that Christians had in their minds of what Jesus actually looked like. And so you give them this portrait that looks like a family member whose picture you just like hang up in your living room. A photo basically. Yeah. So this like portrait studio vibe, is this the thing that really makes it go global? Well, that's why people were so drawn to it was that studio portrait vibe.
看起来像照片的耶稣肖像，然后它符合了基督徒脑海中耶稣真实长相的形象，这真是太了不起了。所以你给他们这幅看起来像家庭成员的肖像，你就像把它挂在客厅里一样。基本上是一张照片。是的。所以这种肖像摄影棚的氛围，是让它走向全球的原因吗？嗯，人们之所以被它吸引，正是因为那种摄影棚肖像的氛围。
But what really made it go global was an incredible mass distribution effort during World War II. And that effort was called Christ in Every Purse. Okay. It has a name. Christ in Every Purse. So what was that? It's pretty much what it sounds like.
但真正让它走向全球的是二战期间令人难以置信的大规模分发工作。那项工作被称为“每个钱包里的基督”。好吧。它有一个名字。每个钱包里的基督。那么那是什么？听起来基本上就是那样。
It was a huge project that was started by Christians in Indiana to get head of Christ images that were about the size of baseball cards, handed out to soldiers who wanted them. Every GI was offered this picture, take this picture with you, it's made for your pocket, and many of them did. And it went through the war with them so that when these folks came back, you know, a lot, many of them still had the picture of Jesus and had developed narratives about how important it was and what it meant to them. David says that when he was doing research about Head of Christ,
这是一个由印第安纳州的基督徒发起的巨大项目，旨在将大约棒球卡大小的《基督头像》图像分发给想要它们的士兵。每个美国大兵都被提供了这张照片，带上这张照片，它是为你口袋制作的，许多人确实带了。它伴随着他们经历了战争，所以当这些人回来时，你知道，很多人仍然保留着耶稣的照片，并发展出了关于它有多重要以及它对他们意味着什么的叙述。大卫说，当他在研究《基督头像》时，
he got letters from hundreds of veterans and their families. And those letters talked about how, for the GIs in World War II, that small image became a talisman and a protector, an inspiration, a source of good luck, and also a reminder of fellow soldiers who they'd lost on the battlefield. That's amazing. I mean, it seems like it would become infused with a bunch of power because of that.
他收到了数百名退伍军人和他们家人的来信。这些信件谈到了对于二战中的美国大兵来说，那张小小的图像如何成为护身符和保护者、灵感、好运的来源，以及对他们在战场上失去的战友的提醒。太神奇了。我是说，看起来它因为那个原因被注入了许多力量。
Definitely. And then in the decade after the war, tens of thousands of prints were going out every month. And they were going to Alcoholics Anonymous, they were going to the Salvation Army, and they were going out to all sorts of huge international Christian groups and leagues. They were all a part of this, and they were giving Head of Christ cards away.
绝对是。然后在战后的十年里，每个月都有数万份印刷品发出。它们被送往匿名戒酒互助社，被送往救世军，并被送往各种巨大的国际基督教团体和联盟。他们都是其中的一部分，他们都在赠送《基督头像》卡片。
And in the US, the spread of Solomon's image also synced up with this much larger effort to inject Christianity into public spaces. After the war, in the sort of Cold War setting, there were movements to put that image of Jesus in settings like courtrooms and libraries and public buildings and to blur any distinction of sacred and secular. That movement actually succeeded in the mid-1950s, around the same time that the phrase, under God, was added to the Pledge of Allegiance. Head of Christ was being hung in public schools and hospitals
在美国，萨尔曼图像的传播也与将基督教注入公共空间的更大努力同步。战后，在冷战背景下，有运动将耶稣的形象置于法庭、图书馆和公共建筑等场所，并模糊神圣与世俗的界限。那场运动实际上在20世纪50年代中期取得了成功，大约在“在上帝之下”这一短语被加入效忠誓词的同一时间。《基督头像》被挂在全国各地的公立学校和医院
and all sorts of public buildings all over the country. Historian Edward Bloom says the biggest impact of this supersaturation of the globe with this image was that Solomon's head of Christ then eclipsed most other images of Jesus in the popular imagination. Before 1940, you just see lots of more localized images of Jesus. There's a lot more flexibility in how people present Jesus, how they alter images of him. And really after the Warner-Solomon revolution in the image, it became the Ur symbol, became the symbol by which all other symbols that were then judged.
以及各种公共建筑中。历史学家爱德华·布鲁姆说，这种全球范围内图像过度饱和的最大影响是，萨尔曼的《基督头像》随后在流行想象中掩盖了大多数其他耶稣形象。1940年之前，你只是看到许多更本土化的耶稣形象。人们在如何呈现耶稣、如何改变他的形象方面有更多的灵活性。而真正到了华纳·萨尔曼的图像革命之后，它成为了原始符号，成为了判断所有其他符号的符号。
If it was close enough to Solomon's head of Christ, that could be what Jesus looked like, but if it was too far, then it was just symbolic or metaphorical. Solomon's head of Christ became the head of Christ, not a head of Christ, for how people not only in the United States but throughout the world then judged what Jesus actually would have looked like.
如果它足够接近萨尔曼的《基督头像》，那可能是耶稣的样子，但如果太远，那只是象征性的或隐喻性的。萨尔曼的《基督头像》成为了“基督头像”，而不是“一个基督头像”，不仅在美国，而且在全世界，人们都以此来判断耶稣真实的样子。
This one image was so wildly successful that Solomon's publishers at Warner Press went to him and they said, we want more of this, give us more Head of Christ, please. And so, Solomon, who passed away in 1968, made many more religious paintings featuring Jesus in all these different scenes. And so, even as the scenes changed, the Jesuses still looked like the guy from the Head of Christ painting. And so I think you can trace a through line
这一幅画如此大获成功，以至于萨尔曼在华纳出版社的出版商找到他，他们说，我们想要更多这样的，请给我们更多《基督头像》。所以，1968年去世的萨尔曼创作了更多以耶稣为主角的宗教画，涵盖了所有这些不同的场景。因此，即使场景变了，耶稣看起来仍然像《基督头像》画中的那个人。所以我认为你可以画出一条贯穿线，
from Solomon's Head of Christ and all of those Head of Christ inspired pieces that he did much later to a lot of our popular culture depictions of Jesus today. And that image of Jesus, which is so fully soaked into our popular consciousness, of course, he's a white man. He's got these blue-gray eyes, this straight Roman nose.
从萨尔曼的《基督头像》以及他后来创作的所有受《基督头像》启发的作品，一直到今天我们流行文化中对耶稣的许多描绘。而那个完全渗透进我们大众意识的耶稣形象，当然，他是一个白人。他有这些蓝灰色的眼睛，这种笔直的罗马鼻。
And so when head of Christ became the dominant portrayal of Jesus, that portrayal really helped crystallize this single popular image of this guy who is white. I mean, whiteness is a very thorny and big concept, which many, many books have been written about, and it's got too much to go into here. But like, in terms of the historical Jesus, what do we know or what do we think we know about what he might have looked like? As you were just suggesting, there is a lot to say about this, and we won't do it here. But what we do know, of course, is that Jesus was a Jewish man who was born in what is now the West Bank in Palestine. And although the Bible
所以当《基督头像》成为耶稣的主导形象时，那种描绘确实有助于结晶这个白人男性的单一流行形象。我是说，白人是一个非常棘手且宏大的概念，许多、许多书都写过它，这里有太多内容无法一一详述。但就像，就历史上的耶稣而言，我们知道什么，或者我们认为我们知道什么关于他可能长什么样？正如你刚才所暗示的，关于这一点有很多可说的，我们在这里不会这样做。但我们当然知道的是，耶稣是一个出生在现在巴勒斯坦西岸地区的犹太人。虽然圣经
doesn't tell us much about what he looked like, lots of people think that he would have been at the very least a lot more brown than the Jesus that's portrayed in Salmon's Head of Christ and in the subsequent renderings inspired by Head of Christ. Warner Salmon was a white Christian artist who painted a world famous image of a white Jesus. And what made the image so meaningful to so many Americans was its whiteness. It gave Americans, particularly white Americans, a Jesus that was theirs, their take. This is art historian David Morgan again.
没有告诉我们太多关于他长什么样，但很多人认为他至少会比萨尔曼《基督头像》中描绘的耶稣以及随后受《基督头像》启发的渲染图中的耶稣要黑得多。华纳·萨尔曼是一位白人基督徒艺术家，他画了一幅举世闻名的白人耶稣形象。而让这幅图像对如此多美国人如此有意义的是它的白人特征。它给了美国人，特别是白人美国人，一个属于他们的耶稣，他们的版本。这是艺术史学家大卫·摩根。
It gave that image a special, comforting, reliable portrait of not only who Jesus was, but who they are as Jesus people. And race is very much a part of this. They wanted to see a white Jesus. But as much as white Americans fell in love with this image, they were not the only ones who used it a lot in their homes and churches. But we can talk about that after the break. Okay, we'll do that after the break.
它给了那个形象一个特殊的、令人安慰的、可靠的肖像，不仅是关于耶稣是谁，而且是关于他们作为耶稣信徒是谁。种族在其中占很大一部分。他们想看到一个白人耶稣。但尽管白人美国人爱上了这个形象，他们并不是唯一在家里和教堂里大量使用它的人。但我们可以在休息后谈谈这个。好的，我们休息后再谈。
Okay, so before the break we were talking specifically about what this white Jesus meant to white Americans, especially white Christians. And so I'm curious about what this image meant to non-white Christians. Yeah, so Head of Christ was not just popular among white Christians. You could find Salmon's image in the homes and the churches of brown and black Christians too. I mean, I know in my family, both my grandma and my great grandma, who were very religious
好的，休息前我们专门谈论了这个白人耶稣对白人美国人，特别是白人基督徒意味着什么。所以我很好奇这个形象对非白人基督徒意味着什么。是的，所以《基督头像》不仅在白人基督徒中很受欢迎。你也可以在棕色和黑色基督徒的家里和教堂里找到萨尔曼的图像。我是说，我知道在我家里，我的祖母和曾祖母，她们是非常虔诚的
black women, they definitely had things around their houses with the head of Christ image on it. And so in black churches, you might have seen Solomon's head of Christ in the vestibules or on people's Bibles, maybe in the sanctuary, and very, very likely on those handheld paper church fans that people would use to cool themselves during service. So why do you think black Christians also use this image? I mean, if white Christians saw themselves in this rendering of white Jesus, what did non-white Christians, what did they get out of this image?
黑人女性，她们家里肯定有带有《基督头像》图像的东西。所以，在黑人教堂里，你可能在门厅或人们的圣经上，也许在圣殿里，非常、非常可能在人们在礼拜期间用来给自己降温的手持纸质教堂扇子上看到萨尔曼的《基督头像》。那么你认为为什么黑人基督徒也使用这个形象呢？我是说，如果白人基督徒在这个白人耶稣的渲染中看到了自己，那么非白人基督徒，他们从这个形象中得到了什么？
So I talked with a former pastor named Willie James Jennings about this. He teaches theology and Africana studies at Yale Divinity School, and he says one reason you find white Jesus in black Christian spaces has to do with capitalism. Historically, it's been white companies, not black ones, that control the production of religious goods. And those companies aren't necessarily thinking about diversity. They're thinking about which Jesus image is going to make their Bibles and their church fans sell.
所以我为此采访了一位名叫威利·詹姆斯·詹宁斯的前牧师。他在耶鲁神学院教授神学和非洲研究，他说你在黑人基督教空间中发现白人耶稣的一个原因与资本主义有关。从历史上看，控制宗教商品生产的一直是白人公司，而不是黑人公司。而这些公司并不一定考虑多样性。他们考虑的是哪种耶稣形象会让他们的圣经和教堂扇子畅销。
And so to place a white Jesus on a fan that you're trying to sell made perfect sense. And for black folks, without control over that economy, we were often at the receiving end of that work. So what this meant was that you had church communities that were flooded with fans because we got a good deal on a package of 50. Jennings also says that black and brown Christians who were part of a society that pushed white Jesus for centuries, sometimes understandably came to envision
所以把一个白人耶稣放在你试图销售的扇子上是完全合理的。而对于黑人来说，由于无法控制那种经济，我们经常处于那种工作的接收端。这意味着你的教会社区里充斥着扇子，因为我们以50个为一包的价格买到了划算的货。詹宁斯还说，几个世纪以来一直推崇白人耶稣的社会中的黑人和棕色基督徒，有时可以理解地开始自己设想
Christ that way themselves. There is a way of understanding our devotion to God that accepts the white Jesus image as normal. People when, you know, they were asked to close their eyes and pray, it would not be unusual for people, not only people of African descent, but people all over the world. When they close their eyes and think about the Jesus
基督是那个样子。有一种理解我们对上帝的奉献的方式，它接受白人耶稣形象作为常态。当人们，你知道，被要求闭上眼睛祈祷时，人们，不仅是非洲裔，而且是全世界的人，闭上眼睛思考耶稣时，这并不罕见
who they're praying to, he looks like that man that is on that fan. But then in the 1960s, a lot of black churchgoers started to rethink their use of images like head of Christ. This was the era of black is beautiful racial pride. There was this huge shift in racial consciousness that permeated all sectors of black American life, including how black folks worshiped.
他们正在祈祷的对象，他看起来就像那个扇子上的男人。但后来在20世纪60年代，许多黑人教会成员开始重新思考他们对《基督头像》这类图像的使用。那是“黑人是美丽的”种族自豪感的时代。种族意识发生了巨大的转变，渗透到黑人美国生活的各个领域，包括黑人如何礼拜。
And so churches started to get rid of depictions of white Jesus, and they started replacing those with images that looked more like them and that portrayed a religious life in which they could see themselves. Black churches started to get a better sense of the importance of challenging the images that were being put in front of us that underwrote white dominance. And so that's when you start to have people change out those fans,
所以教堂开始摆脱白人耶稣的描绘，他们开始用看起来更像他们自己、描绘了他们能看到自己的宗教生活的图像来取代那些。黑人教堂开始更好地理解挑战那些被摆在我们面前、为白人统治背书的图像的重要性。所以这就是你开始让人更换那些扇子的时候，
start to have churches change out their stained glass windows, start to have churches create murals and paintings and pictures that depicted black life and the beauty of black life as fundamental to shaping our devotion. Okay, so I definitely get the idea here, but could you give me an example of what this looked like? Sure, so I mean, there are countless examples of this, but one of my favorites actually isn't about
开始让教堂更换他们的彩色玻璃窗，开始让教堂创作描绘黑人生活以及黑人生活之美的壁画、绘画和图片，作为塑造我们奉献精神的基础。好的，所以我完全理解这里的想法，但你能给我一个这看起来是什么样子的例子吗？当然，我是说，这方面的例子数不胜数，但我最喜欢的例子之一其实不是关于
Head of Christ specifically, but it is about putting more black Jesus imagery in a black church. Specifically, the 16th Street Baptist Church in Birmingham, Alabama. In 1963, the KKK bombed that church, killing four black girls. And in that bombing, some of the church's stained glass was damaged, including windows depicting white Christs. Two years after that bombing, the church installed what's known as the Whale's Window, which sits above the main entrance to the church. And the Whale's Window is this huge, gorgeous stained glass depiction
《基督头像》的具体内容，但它是关于在黑人教堂中放置更多黑人耶稣意象。具体来说，伯明翰的第16街浸信会教堂，阿拉巴马州。1963年，三K党炸毁了那座教堂，杀死了四个黑人女孩。在那次爆炸中，教堂的一些彩色玻璃受损，包括描绘白人基督的窗户。爆炸发生两年后，教堂安装了被称为“鲸鱼之窗”的窗户，它位于教堂正门上方。而“鲸鱼之窗”是这幅巨大、华丽的彩色玻璃描绘
of a black Jesus dressed in all white. And he's set against this backdrop that just shimmers with all these different shades of blue and purple. And there's this bright rainbow that fans out between his arms as he stretches his hands towards the sky. Roman, it is a beautiful piece of art. Yeah. And there have been several popular renderings of Black Jesus,
一个穿着全白衣服的黑人耶稣。他以一个闪烁着各种深浅蓝色和紫色的背景为衬托。当他向天空伸出双手时，一道明亮的彩虹在他双臂之间扇开。罗曼，这是一件美丽的艺术品。是的。而且已经有几个流行的黑人耶稣渲染图，
at least among Black folks. But still, nothing with the kind of singular global impact of Head of Christ. So, at the end of the day, despite all of these alternatives, the head of Christ image persists and it's still super powerful and pernicious. And it still feels to a lot of people like the right version of Jesus. It's really hard to undo that. When you see a black Jesus or Korean Jesus or an indigenous Jesus, it's usually called black Jesus or Korean Jesus or an indigenous Jesus. It's usually called black Jesus or Korean Jesus or Indian or native Jesus,
至少在黑人中是这样。但仍然，没有什么能像《基督头像》那样具有单一的全球影响力。所以，归根结底，尽管有所有这些替代方案，但《基督头像》的形象仍然存在，而且它仍然超级强大且有害。对许多人来说，它仍然感觉像是耶稣的正确版本。这真的很难扭转。当你看到一个黑人耶稣或韩国耶稣或土著耶稣时，它通常被称为黑人耶稣或韩国耶稣或土著耶稣。它通常被称为黑人耶稣或韩国耶稣或印度或本土耶稣，
whereas Solomon's Jesus is just Christ. It's just Jesus. Yeah. I mean, what's amazing to me is how much the objects that shape and represent our values all come from real specific decisions. Like it was a series of actions by a group of humans in the upper Midwest who decided to depict Jesus
而萨尔曼的耶稣只是“基督”。他只是“耶稣”。是的。我是说，让我感到惊讶的是，塑造和代表我们价值观的物体在多大程度上都来自真正具体的决定。就像它是美国中西部一群人类的一系列行动，他们决定描绘耶稣
in this particular way and had that not happen, had this specific story not happen, this specific chain of events, and then this thing was mass produced and then it was rallied around, it just didn't have to be this way. Yes, I think that's exactly right. Well this is fascinating stuff and I love that so much comes down to this single image. What an amazing story.
以这种特定的方式，如果那没有发生，如果这个特定的故事没有发生，这一连串特定的事件，然后这个东西被大规模生产，然后人们围绕它团结起来，它本来不必是这样的。是的，我认为那完全正确。好吧，这真是迷人的东西，我喜欢这么多东西归结为这一单一形象。多么精彩的故事。
Well thank you so much Christopher, I appreciate it. You are welcome. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. Mixed by Martín González Music by Swan Real with additional music by George Langford and Jamila Sandoto Sinai. Fact-checking by Graham Haysha. Special thanks to David Morgan for all his help researching this story. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Jason DeLeon, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime,
好吧，非常感谢你，克里斯托弗，我很感激。不客气。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，乔治·兰福德和贾米拉·桑多托·西奈提供额外音乐。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。特别感谢大卫·摩根为研究这个故事提供的所有帮助。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、薇薇安·雷、拉莎·马顿、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、
Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky and our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99i.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Blue Sky和我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一期往期节目，网址是99i.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。